[Music]
how many of you guys would consider
yourselves goal oriented
not just saying it as an adjective but
really thrive on having a goal and
meeting that goal
i am definitely a goal-oriented person
i love having a long-term goal
and working towards it knowing that each
of my movements was going to eventually
help me reach that goal
but did you know in a survey
only six percent of people
end up being in their childhood dream
career
i fall into that 90
94 of people that didn't
my childhood dream was to become a world
known
a world-renowned pianist
and at the age of four you'd be kind of
confused not knowing how serious you can
go and how would you know at four years
old well i know how i knew
my mom told me that was going to be my
goal
my mom was a piano teacher
and she looking back i'm realizing
really wanted to become a world-renowned
pianist
and she saw me as an opportunity to
fulfill her lifelong dream and obviously
it was with well intentions
and i'm so thankful for all the
sacrifices that she was offering so that
i can become really good at piano
but nevertheless
from 4 to 18 years old i'm realizing
that it was not my goal it was something
that was imposed on me
and that's kind of what i want to share
with you guys today
i believe that life is really not about
having that perfectly
crystallized plan that you're going to
work towards
rather
you should have the flexibility of being
adaptable so that you can pivot whenever
you need to depending on where you are
in your life stages
so let me share with you guys three
crucial parts of my life where i had to
pivot and i increased my ability to be
okay with uncertainty
so like i said my childhood was
pretty much made up of anything that was
related to piano so if you guys were to
think about your childhood you probably
can come up with easily several games
that you play with your friends or
favorite activities that you had whether
it be sports or music or anything else
that brought you joy
mine it primarily consisted of two
activities
one
it was
practicing the piano
two
performing the piano
anything else that was outside of these
two buckets was deemed extracurricular
and
essentially a waste of time so
you can imagine
practicing the piano really became my
life
and i found
comfort in that because i knew exactly
what i wanted to do i knew that when i
went to college i wanted to go to the
juilliard school so that i could major
in piano and that would help me become a
world-renowned renowned pianist
looking back i'm realizing that i didn't
have any
ownership on creating my own goals and
that
in turn didn't allow me to be okay in
the discomfort of being in uncertainty
so if i had to assess it at that time i
was about 0
comfortable being an uncertainty during
my childhood
what i did learn is
that i was super laser focused
you can imagine if you had three to four
hours of practicing the piano every day
you can get very good at focusing on a
specific task
the other thing i learned was i was able
to do repetitive tests day in day out
without going crazy
you can imagine playing the same piece
over and over again trying to perfect
that note trying to bring in the
tonation
and to make everything work together
while you do it in one shot
and the other thing that i learned
was being able to have that drive
because you knew that you had that goal
so i take all of this
to say that i did learn a lot during my
childhood
but again the con of it was that i was
not comfortable with uncertainty
so i went to ucla not juilliard
for as a music major
and i
realized at that time very quickly that
i didn't want to continue with music
i thought that at least getting a degree
in music was one way that i can play
pay respect to my mom who sacrificed 14
years of a lot of money a lot of time so
that i can get a music
a music degree
but towards the end when i was a senior
i realized that i couldn't be a musician
for two reasons
number one was i wanted to be able to
support my parents financially because
they went through a hard time when i was
younger and i definitely wanted to
support them and number two i really
wanted to help others and i didn't see
how i could as a musician
you can argue that as a musician you can
make people's lives better you're
bringing joy to people
but i wanted to do something that was a
lot more tangible
and so
and as a fourth as a senior in college
and as an immigrant i'm realizing now
that actually was at a little bit of a
disadvantage because i wasn't really
aware of the potential job opportunities
or careers that i had
i had a very limited
amount of knowledge of what i thought i
can do and they were basically into
three buckets
healthcare
law
and business
and business i excluded right away
because to me what i was taught was
business
basically could be that you can own
liquor stores or you can own dry
cleaners and there was not much outside
of
that and i eventually ended up in
healthcare because it just felt like it
was something that i would enjoy doing
it would be helping a lot of people and
you can make a comfortable salary so
after a lot of debate and a lot of
prayer i landed on optometry
and at this point
i'm realizing that the uncertainty that
i faced was very uncomfortable because i
was at about zero percent uncertainty
coming into college towards the end when
i made that decision
i was at about maybe 10
i just really did not feel comfortable
not knowing what was going to be my next
steps and there was a lot of anxiety
that i felt during that summer when i
was really grappling with how to figure
out what my goals were
i went to optometry school
graduated
and i knew that i wanted to do something
with business because i really just
always had an entrepreneurial spirit
so i graduated from optometry school and
i decided to open a practice
and i do want to share a little bit more
of a personal story with you right
before i open my practice
i was forced to become
about 75 okay with uncertainty
now let me share with you guys what
happened
so right before i uh opened my first
practice
i was pregnant with my first daughter
kala
and i had
serious complications
later on um i really i realized that i
was diagnosed with something called
sepsis with dic which was a very serious
condition and i had almost died and
going through that experience where
you're not certain if you're going to be
given another day to live
it really makes you 100 exposed to
uncertainty because what can be more
uncertain
than having uncertainty about if you're
going to be able to live to see another
day
so after that experience
i've been very thankful for every day
that i get to live
i've increased my dependence on god and
just have been so thankful for every day
that i've been given
but on top of that i've been very
comfortable with uncertainty after that
and coupling that with the uncertainty
of starting a practice cold that really
made me become about 75
okay with uncertainty
and
just not to glaze over the startup part
as well of the business side because
that in itself had a lot of
trials and tribulations and discomfort
but overall just coming out of that
stage in my life
i've learned a lot about how to start a
business
i learned about the importance of life
and i learned most importantly not to
take each day for granted
so
on to the last part of my journey the
gsb
so i started the gsb in january 2021
which was earlier this year
and i'm going to be graduating in about
a month in december 2021
and
there's a lot that i've learned here
coming in i was at about like i said 75
okay with uncertainty and what i was
hoping to get out of this experience was
to become more like 100 okay with
uncertainty and i think i'm getting
there
so what have i been doing this past year
at the gsb
well i've been doing a lot of
self-reflecting
and this speech
this talk is what came out of it
i'm realizing at each of those important
pivotal parts of my life there is a lot
of life lessons that i've learned
a lot of skill sets that i developed and
a lot of relationships that i built with
different people in my life
and i'm not saying that i'm 100 okay
with uncertainty if i were to give you
guys a visual if you see this
uncertainty cloud right in front of you
i used to want to get through it with a
wind blower
and i would try to dispel it as quickly
as possible so i would
just always be thinking about like all
the things that i could do to get rid of
this uncertainty because it made me very
anxious and very stressed not knowing
what was going to be next and not having
a goal that i can work towards
but now if you can imagine this
instead of going at it with a wind
blower
i
walk around
the fog
and i kind of look around to see if
there's any angles or different angles
that i can approach it or if there's any
openings or hints that can help me try
to get rid of this uncertainty cloud
and i think that helps me because
it makes me okay to be in that
discomfort it reduces my anxiety level
and it also lets me excited about the
future knowing that i can pivot at any
time
and so
now that i'm about to graduate
my goal loosely speaking it's not a
clearly defined crystallized goal by any
mean
but i do know that i want to start
building up practices and i'm going to
primarily focus in the medical spa space
and optometry
for now
and so what i want you guys to take away
from this are some of the tips that i've
learned through my journey
number one
it's okay not to have a crystallized and
fully fleshed out plan or goal
it's really okay
you have to imagine that there's going
to be a lot of times that you pivot
your interest might change
your strengths might get developed more
on a certain part and you want to use
that strength you might realize that you
have some weaknesses and before you
because of that weakness you wouldn't be
have you wouldn't have that ability to
reach this certain goal but now that you
can grow that weakness it's now become a
strength and so now you can pivot and
change your goals
so that's one
the next one is
it's okay to change your goals and pivot
and the reason why i say this as a
separate tip is because sometimes people
feel really uncomfortable or they feel
like they're failing when they change
their goals because they told people
that hey this is what i want to do and
when they feel that they it isn't
something that they want to continue
doing
then they feel embarrassed or a sense of
shame that they didn't follow through or
deliver what they thought they wanted to
do
if this is the case i would recommend
hiding it keep it with yourself don't
share it until you've accomplished it
that's worked really well for me
and the third is
just know that this really is not a
destination but rather a journey that
you're going through and you should be
enjoying
and
the way that you can do it is instead of
thinking i have to create a three a five
or a ten year plan
think of it more in terms of a shorter
sprint so maybe it's a six-month plan or
it's a year plan but just give yourself
the ability to create almost like an mvp
and you know this is a business school
so i'm using words that um resonate
an mvp of your goal and just be able to
have it but know that you can come back
to edit it or change it at any time
so what are my goals at this point
it's twofold
one
is to be a hundred percent okay with
uncertainty
and two
is to remind myself every day that life
is really about the journey
and not the destination
thank you
[Music]